So we've looked at radical form throughout this lesson. We know that this
really represents a power divided by a root. We can also write radical form in
exponential form using a fractional exponent. So let's work in the reverse
direction this time. let's go from radical form to the exponential form. Try
expressing each of these radicals with one fractional exponent. Be sure you
raise the entire radical to the exponent. Keep in mind that when you have
something than just a variable and an exponent inside a radical, you'd erase
this entire radical to the fractional exponent. Here we can also simplify
further since the 4 m squared is the same thing as 2m raised to the second
power. 2 squared is 4 and m squared is m squared. We're raising the power to a
power so we really multiply these powers together to get 2m to the 2 3rds.
These two should connect from what we know since. 2 m squared is 4 m squared,
and then we have a root in our denominator, or a cube root. Take some time on
these, and when you're ready, enter your answers here.